This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say
trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we break down the psychology of our 20s. This episode was listener requested. Actually, it was requested a lot of times, a lot of times. And,
And as with all listener requested episodes, I always am like, how have I never done this before? Because when you start thinking about it, a lot of us live with shame about who we are and we carry that in silence. We are ashamed each of us, I think, of something in our lives, of our past, our past mistakes, maybe our bodies, our choices, our identity, our entire personhood. at times. And that shame takes over quite literally everything. It can become a constant companion in everything that we do so that when we wake up, we feel like we aren't good enough. When we want to take a risk or do something brave, we can't trust ourselves. When good things happen to us, we think we don't deserve them. Shame is above all else, at its core, at its beginnings, it's a social or moral emotion. That's what it was, what kind of evolved.
to be. We feel it very intensely in situations where we believe that we have upset, offended, disgusted someone, or when we go against some social norm or moral held by society that means that perhaps we deserve to be punished, outcast, we are unworthy of acceptance and forgiveness. This is what makes it a deeply painful emotion that seems so hardwired into our social brains. It's a way to make us behave, make sure that we are good boys and girls, and also that we hide behavior that we think others will judge us for. We hide ourselves away altogether when we think that our mistakes or something about us makes us unsavory as a whole, not worthy of being seen. This is the problem with chronic shame. It's that we don't just feel this emotion in response to specific circumstances because that would be guilt.
We feel shame even when we are alone, even when there is no audience, there is no offensive behavior that we have committed. And that is the kind of shame that I want to discuss today. Toxic, chronic shame that just doesn't accompany a hiccup or small mistake, but which kind of ends up feeling like part of our DNA. And that's what it means to be shame bound. And it's one of the big battles that a lot of us have to overcome in our 20s. is to be released from this very oppressive force that keeps us small. And that is what shame does.
Shame keeps us small because it becomes self-imposed. At some point, we don't need another person to give us a dirty look or to humiliate us or to expose us, reject us. All of those things, we end up doing them to ourselves in a way as a way to stop us from being critiqued and seen. and because we almost anticipate that if we were to show up and try hard and be visible, someone is going to find something about us that we deserve to be ashamed of. I don't think that it will come as a surprise that, sadly, this pattern has a lot of roots in trauma, and not just the big trauma that we think of,
but small moments where we were made to feel terrible and disgusting because of part of who we were. So let's talk about it today. I want to really discuss how shame gets implanted in our self-concept, what that feels like, what that does to our ambition, what that does to our direction, but also some of the best advice I have encountered in a long time on how to release ourselves from being shame-bound. I know this is something that a lot of us live with for different reasons. and we're going to discuss those as well.
But I really hope that if the thing, what you might actually realize is that the thing that is keeping you from, everything you might want, everything that you could be, is not a lack of effort. It's not because you're lazy. It's not because you don't know what you want. It's not because you're not capable.
It's because of an inherent shame that you feel around being seen and being loud and being heard. So, without further ado, let's discuss the psychology of shame. Brunay Brown is one of my favorite, favorite researchers, people in general, and in her very well-known TED Talk, which is called The Power of Vulnerability, it was released almost 14 years ago. It's incredibly popular. It's a must watch. She says that shame is essentially the fear of disconnection, and it sits very closely besides, our fear of loneliness, of judgment, ostracization, and social pain.
Because basically, it is posing a very insidious and toxic line of questioning. Is there something about me that if other people were to know or were to see, they would believe I wasn't worthy of belonging? And if there is, I better hide it or else how could I be loved and accepted? There is this kind of toss-up in our brain. Either I can be truthful, open, I can be myself. and maybe I won't ever be loved or I can be secretive and I can conceal who I really am and maybe I can be loved. Those in our mind when we are shame bound are the only two options.
We never once think, well, maybe the things I'm ashamed of others would just see as part of me. That would just be something that they love and that they would nurture. That's not how chronic shame works. It's a very limited belief that if you are unworthy in some ways, you better be hiding that part of yourself. This results in a number of really, really unfortunate, unhappy behaviours and compulsions, like the need to self-isolate. If you've ever found yourself, you know, self-isolating after a big social event and you, and you don't think that you're an introvert or hiding away after like a really long, exhausting day in front of people or after a big presentation or after you've spoken your mind,
feeling the need to be silent. Maybe that comes from shame. There's also an intense embarrassment or anxiety in social situations. There is a self-loathing. There is a self-sabotage, feeling of rejection, all of which stop us from attempting anything that might make us feel seen, because that is what shame does. It's a minimiser. Literally, think about the physical actions and behaviors, the physicalities that accompany feeling shame. Think about the last time that you were like, oh my gosh, I feel ashamed. You were probably not making eye contact. You were slouching your shoulders, lowering your head, almost curling into yourself. Physically, socially, mentally, shame's goal is to shrink us. The opposite of shame in that sense is self-acceptance, accepting who you are, your body,
your identity, how you've gotten here, even if you have regrets, And that self-acceptance, that self-confidence. That is what makes us expansive, self-assured creatures, passionate, outspoken, loud about life creatures. And that's the goal here. That's the direction that we want to move in. But before we get there, I do need to give you a few more crucial details about the pathology and the underworkings, underpinnings of shame.
So shame is universal. I know it feels like quite a solitary experience. That is the nature of it. But the only people on this planet who don't experience shame are those who have essentially no human empathy. They have no desire to be liked or be seen or accepted by others. So we might call these people psychopaths, right? And a few studies have found a very strong association between psychopathy and low shame-proneness, which basically means that even if you were to do something that is like objectively wrong and immoral,
you still don't feel bad about it. There was a really fascinating case study that I dug out of the archives when I was looking into this. And it's on a man, this unnamed man, who was in prison in the US. And he had admitted his crime, his crime was armed robbery and actually resulted in someone being murdered. But even years later, he felt no remorse at all. He felt no shame.
He believed that he was justified because of how he was raised. And when he was in prison, he continued to steal, to live. lie to do interviews where he almost bragged about his crimes, whatever he could, to basically get his way, even when it meant others were hurt, all because of that, you know, that part of us that that lights up when we hurt, we injure, we upset someone else, our shame center, his basically wasn't working. And that's kind of the alternative that we're working with. Shame is also very different to guilt. I know they are sometimes used interchangeably, but guilt, I actually believe it's adaptive. You know, it is tied to a specific situation in which we have done something
objectively wrong. We've made a mistake and we can say, you know, I feel guilty for how I've acted because I've messed up, I've hurt someone. And that acknowledgement of a specific instance in which we have gone against our own, kind of our own expectations for ourselves, our own standards, that makes us a better person. We bring ourselves back in line. Shame, on the other hand, it does not make you a better person. At no point is shame going to make you better. In fact, it's just so incredibly destructive because it rests on the premises that it's not just that we sometimes make mistakes, is that our whole sense of self, we are a mistake.
We are wrong. Even when we have no evidence for that, even when it's not situation specific like guilt. Oftentimes, when you feel shame, you'll begin to notice that no one's even around. You haven't hurt anyone. You are a good person. There's nothing that you can think of, but you still feel this deep sting just by existing. Also, I think the other key point here that I didn't mention before, guilt actually has somewhere to go, right?
You know, we can rectify our mistakes, we can apologize, it can motivate good behavior. Shame lingers. It doesn't exit. It just implants deeper and deeper within us. Something really important to remember is that, no matter how long you have carried your shame, no matter how long you and shame have shared the same home, been companions, none of us were born ashamed of who we are. At some point, and this is a sad thing to say actually, someone had to teach you that there was
something about how you look, how you act, your identity, your existence that was offensive to them and that shouldn't be seen. think about the shame that a lot of people used to associate with being queer, with being part of the LGBTQIA plus community. At some point, someone said something really demeaning to you, or maybe someone's parents said that they would be ashamed to have a queer son or a queer daughter. Or, you know, you see things in the media that just villainize people who are literally just living their life. That is leading, probably led a lot of people to internalize that therefore they are shameful and that is not the case. or the shame of making a mistake as a child and being criticized for so much more than the action, you know, instead of just your parents scolding you and saying,
I can't believe you spilled the milk, it's, I can't believe you are so clumsy, you are so lazy, you are worthless, you are useless. Can you see that shame is not about what you've done? It's associated with who you are. And how can any part of who you are be inherently shameful? It becomes implanted in our minds until the point where it is self-imposed. We end up using it against ourselves without ever needing anyone else to tell it to us again. I heard Dr. Pete Levine, he's a very well-known trauma doctor and trauma specialist.
Look him up if you're interested in this. But I heard him say in a video the other day that shame is like a cancer that grows from the injury of trauma and from the wound of betrayal, especially interpersonal trauma and interpersonal betrayal, which is basically the trauma we encounter from the transgressions and actions of others, especially people that we trust. And that cancer from these situations becomes deeply lodged in our bodies and our minds, and it affects and infects all other aspects of our life. Your relationships, how you show up at work, in class,
how you walk into a room, what you feel you deserve from your life, nothing remains untouched. So how do we get to this place? This doesn't just happen. How do we get here? Well, Dr. Levine, same guy, he suggested that there are two specific pathways through which we adopt chronic shame, or we become shame bound. The first is if you are traumatized or humiliated as a young child or a teenager, either by a parent, a sibling, a friend, a bully, a teacher, whoever it may be, someone trespasses against your sense of self-worth by harming you, by making you feel useless and small. And because of our limited critical thinking skills at the time or our limited life experience as children, the only way that we can make sense of what we're
experiencing is by internalizing what has happened, which causes us to basically assume that something must be fundamentally wrong with us. We lay the below. on our own innate badness because we have to assume that we are the cause. We are the common denominator because how else could we continue to trust people? How could we continue to trust people that we rely on like our parents, like our teachers, like our family? They must be right. This is actually part of what he proposes is a survival strategy.
We cannot possibly think that the people that we rely on for security and safety, would be wrong about things like this because then they could be wrong about other things and then, you know, who could help us? The other element of this occurring in childhood, especially is that all the people that we feel ashamed or feel shamed by are often older and wiser. And so we deduced that they must know something about our character that we don't. They are the truth holders. We have this big red cross on us. They must be correct. We are wrong and awful and bad because they told us that we were. The more experiences we have like this, the more difficult it is to deny our badness, the more oppressive and entrenched, the shame becomes. This can also be more pronounced
for people who, who's just identities in general criticized by a very oppressive, dominating, prejudice society. We do see higher rates of internalized shame in the queer community, amongst people of color amongst people in marginalized religions because there is this system that says and there is just you know it's held up by the media it's held up by discrimination by prejudice by stereotypes that essentially says we don't really like you that much and there's no reason that we don't like you there's just some part of you that's wrong and it's just so awful that children from a very young age begin to pick that up shame i really want this to be very apparent shame is not dispersed equally across society.
The second way that chronic shame develops can come about a little bit later, and it really comes down to a fear of being left out, which feeds off, again, our fear of loneliness, and our fear of being excluded, very human primal fears. I don't think I have to tell you, hopefully, I don't have to tell you that community and belonging are so important. They're just literally our lifeblood. It's one of our foundational,
psychological needs and not just a physical need but an emotional need as well. There's a really well-known study using fMRI technology, which is basically a machine that shows us which parts of our brains are active when we're doing certain things. And it examined the brains of people who were made to feel lonely, disconnected and rejected versus the brains of participants who are made to feel accepted, included and connected. The brain scans of the participants who were made to feel isolated, were just lighting up in the areas of the brain responsible for pain and perceiving danger, meaning that this experience of not being liked or welcomed was physically uncomfortable at times.
Now, if you know what that feels like to have people not like you, and to not only have them not like you, but to make that known, to be openly judged, you are going to work pretty hard to stop that from happening again. and here is where your shame seemingly to you feels useful because you're like, okay, if I listen to my shame, I'll never step out of line. If I listen to my shame, I'll never do something that's wrong. I'll be able to make friends. I'll be loved.
Anytime you go to, therefore, you know, there onwards, go to change anything about yourself, to put yourself out there, to bet on yourself to be authentic, vulnerable. That shameful voice comes in and. says, don't do it. Don't let yourself be seen. The more visible you are, the less safe we are, take a step back. That shameful voice, you think that it's acting as your protector. It's convincing you that it's keeping you safe from rejection and exclusion. But, you know, although our shame likes to masquerade as a form of self-preservation, it ultimately limits your ability to experience life, because it's keeping you tied down.
So that smallness is one of the consequences of letting shame be the loudest voice in the room. And that's actually how I like to think about it. It's the guy in class in your meeting who's always interrupting you. It's the voice that just doesn't know when to shut up. It's the voice that's saying, oh, well, actually this, well, actually that. Another real loss is that when you are shame bound, even when good things happen to you, you still don't believe that you deserve them. When someone listens, when someone lets us be vulnerable and accepts us, we never totally
accept it. We are waiting for the so-called emotional jump scare because our self-concept has been reprogrammed time and time again to assume the worst, to have our guard up, to cut ourselves down before someone else can. Actually, it's really interesting because it's really interesting and this is kind of a side note, but there has been some really cool fascinating research, not cool, but definitely fascinating research that shows that people who experience more shame often are quite obsessed with self-improvement because they are constantly trying to fix or fix something about themselves or to show that they
are deserving of things by working hard to change who they are. And so sometimes it's like, well, I can't have anything that comes easy because I don't deserve it. So there is something deeply, deeply wrong about me that if I focus on self-improvement, on getting really, really fit, on learning or making my life seem perfect, then I can prove that all these good things have actually worked hard for them. So quite an interesting, very interesting point of view, especially as someone who I'm like, ooh, I like work in the self-help, self-improvement space. I want people to get the most out of their life.
It's interesting how many of us might actually be doing that because of a shame of never being good enough. Chronic shame, I think this is very similar, is also reflected often in people pleasing because we, of course, prioritise the opinions of others over our own. We want them to stay happy with us, even if it means a loss of personal identity and less personal fulfillment. And shame can also lead to self-sabotaging behaviors where we consciously undermine our success or our happiness by procrastinating by neglecting opportunities, neglecting relationships, minimizing ourselves in front of others, or even engaging in really risky behaviors to confirm negative beliefs about ourselves because when you have lived that long in shame,
it feels like home. What's that quote? It's like, better the hell you know than the heaven that you don't. And that is where we're at. I think another element of it is also, you know, success. and doing well brings attention. And that spotlight might reveal even more aspects of us that we should be ashamed of. And we can't have that. So, you know, you go out and get drunk the night before a big meeting. You ruin the relationship before it can progress. And at least, you know, you already feel comfortable in that understanding of yourself.
You are a failure. You're not enough. You'll never deserve this. Can you kind of see what Dr. Levine was saying? It is a cancer. The way that shame manifests itself. it metastasizes into everything that we do. So what I want to talk about next is where we can go from here.
We've identified the problem. I think maybe I'm saying things to you and you're just nodding your head, being like, yeah, I already knew that. I've literally lived with this for years. What do I do about it? How do I be more big and vulnerable and authentic when I'm being told by my own brain to be quiet, small, invisible? Well, we are going to talk about all of that and a lot more after this short break,
so stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange, modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we picket here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of Congress. crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack.
So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your
Podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month,
I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark.
Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know
when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app, Search learn the hard way and listen now.
In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. sunlight's the greatest disinfected.
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, the lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice of. served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Shame is kind of like a bad habit. It won't change unless you do.
And I'm not saying it won't change unless you get better and you prove it wrong. I mean that it's always going to feel like you're fighting with yourself until you accept it. until you, it's almost like when you lay back in the ocean and you just let it take you and you lie in it and you realize that you've been struggling against something for so long that if you just turned around and said, it's okay, I see you, I accept this. Maybe it would start to fade a little bit. The person, and I've already mentioned her once in this episode, obviously I am obsessed, but the person I always turned to for advice on this is Brunet Brown.
And obviously, Brunay Brown, she's made her career on shame, guilt, vulnerability. and the best thing she ever said about the shame cycle is that an actual bad person, a person who has done things they deserve to feel ashamed for, they would never sit down and question whether they are a bad person, they would never admit their mistakes. So the very fact that you were considering your worthiness is evidence in yourself that you are worthy. You are someone deserving of love. You have empathy. You are someone who is lovable, someone who can be forgiven. however big or large that mistake was.
And you are actually, it might sound surprising, you are someone who was enough, regardless of what makes you believe that is not true. So there are a few steps we can take to truly accepting that fact. First, don't let your shame be general. Force it to be specific. You know, this sounds very strange, but you see, one of the reasons shame is so good at convincing us that we're worthless is it takes a single instant of,
而实际上，这听起来可能令人惊讶，你是一个本身就足够好的人，无论是什么让你相信这不是真的。所以我们可以采取几个步骤来真正接受这个事实。首先，不要让你的羞耻感变得笼统。强迫它变得具体。你知道，这听起来很奇怪，但你看，羞耻感之所以如此擅长让我们确信自己毫无价值，原因之一在于它只需要一个瞬间，
of embarrassment or a slip up or a thought, and it applies the feeling to everything. So instead of saying, you know, I feel bad because I said the wrong thing to my really good friend and I hurt them, I feel awful because I wish I was a better friend in that moment. Our shame takes that feeling and it removes a bunch of information and it concludes, well, I am bad. I am wrong. I am awful. Even after the situation has long passed.
比如尴尬、失误或是一个念头，然后就把这种感觉放大到一切事物上。所以，与其说“我知道我感觉不好，是因为我对好朋友说了错话伤害了他们，我感到很糟糕，因为我希望当时能做一个更好的朋友”，我们的羞耻感会直接拿走这种感觉，过滤掉大量信息，然后得出结论：“好吧，我很糟糕。我错了。我很糟糕透顶。”甚至在事情过去很久之后依然如此。
that overgeneralization is what causes trouble. So instead, learn to add information back into the negative statements that you tell yourself. You need to realize that shame relies on you taking everything that it says truthfully and not interrogating how it could be so general. You know, are you a really a bad person always, without question, or are you just feeling bad? So I want you to replace the I am awful with, I'm feeling awful. I am wrong with, I'm just assuming that I'm wrong. I feel, I assume, I'm thinking that I am.
这种过度概括就是问题所在。因此，相反，学会把信息重新加回到你对自己说的负面陈述中。你需要意识到，羞耻感依赖于你对它所说的一切深信不疑，而不去质问它怎么能如此笼统。你知道，难道你真的是无时无刻、毫无疑问地都是个糟糕的人，还是你只是现在感觉很糟糕？所以我希望你把“我很糟糕”替换为“我现在感觉很糟糕”。把“我错了”替换为“我只是在假设我错了”。我感觉，我假设，我在想我是……
Use those exact words instead to kind of put some reality back into your faulty thinking. So let's use the example of a really common one. I am an unlovable person to kind of show how this works. Is this statement, I am unlovable, true? is it, you know, is it fact? Could you find this fact on Wikipedia? Has someone done a peer-reviewed experiment on this and come to you with a solid, you know, thesis, conclusion, hypothesis saying, yeah, this is, I've conducted, you know, millions of interviews and I did heaps of studies and, oh, by the way, yes, you are unlovable. Or, or is this an emotions-based conclusion? It's
用这些确切的词语来把一些现实感带回你那有缺陷的思维中。让我们以一个非常普遍的例子为例：“我是个不讨人喜欢的人”，以此来看看这是如何运作的。“我是个不讨人喜欢的人”这个陈述是真的吗？它是事实吗？你能在维基百科上找到这个事实吗？有没有人对此做过同行评审的实验，然后拿着扎实的论文、结论或假设来找你，说：“是的，我采访了成百上千万人，做了大量研究，顺便说一句，是的，你就是不讨人喜欢”？还是说，这是一个基于情绪的结论？它是
emotions-based, right? It's coming from you. So I want you to replace I-M-A-Mobile. I-Mobile. I am with, I feel. I feel like an unlovable person. And then ask why? Is there something that has triggered this feeling? Is there a specific recent memory? Maybe there is. And you can add that in. I feel unlovable because of how badly that date went. I feel unlovable because that person didn't treat me well. That puts distance between you and the immediate like instinct to go to shame. you can kind of now see that this isn't something intrinsic about you. It's actually a feeling, not a fact, and it's about how someone else chose to treat you. That's a sign of their flawed character, not your own.
基于情绪的，对吧？它源于你自己。所以我希望你把“我是个不讨人喜欢的人”中的“我是”替换为“我觉得”。我觉得自己像个不讨人喜欢的人。然后问问为什么？有什么东西触发了这种感觉吗？有没有哪个最近的具体记忆？也许有。你可以把它加进去。我觉得自己不讨人喜欢，是因为那次约会太糟糕了。我觉得自己不讨人喜欢，是因为那个人对我不好。这在你自己和直接涌向羞耻感的本能之间拉开了距离。你现在可以看出，这并不是你内在固有的某种东西，它其实是一种感觉，而不是事实，这与别人选择如何对待你有关。那是他们品格有缺陷的标志，而不是你的问题。
This is not a permanent fact. I just want to say that again. It's a momentary experience based on someone else's actions, not your inherent worth. The other alternative is that you may be searching for a recent memory way you've been made to feel this way. and you just can't find one. It's like no evidence. There's no reason why you should be feeling this way. And it must be based on something else.
这不是一个永久的事实。我想再次强调这一点。这只是一次基于他人行为的暂时体验，而不是你固有价值的体现。另一种可能的情况是，你可能在搜寻最近的记忆，想找找是什么让你有了这种感觉，但你根本找不到。就好像没有任何证据。你根本没有理由产生这种感觉，它一定基于别的东西。
And that thing that it's based on is shame. It's not a real statement. There is no evidence for why you should be feeling this way. It's just shame. That is what it is. Either way, when we rely on those I am broad statements, they are just incorrect because they are way too general. Next, I think it's really worthwhile to explore your shame and try and find an origin point.
而它所基于的东西就是羞耻感。这不是一个真实的陈述。没有任何证据证明你为什么会有这种感觉。这只是羞耻感。事实就是如此。无论如何，当我们依赖那些宽泛的“我是”的陈述时，它们都是不正确的，因为它们实在是太笼统了。接下来，我认为非常值得去探索你的羞耻感，并试着找到它的源头。
Like, you know how every villain has an origin story? Your shame has an origin story as well. As I said before, you know, no one is born feeling, disgusting, undeserving, shameful. It's a learned behavior. It's a learned habit. And when we do the really hard autobiographical work of looking back through our memories and our past, often that becomes very, very clear, very quickly. You can see that there is a line between the thoughts and the feelings you have about yourself now
就像你知道每个反派都有一个起源故事一样，你的羞耻感也有一个起源故事。正如我之前所说，没有人天生就会觉得自己令人厌恶、不配拥有爱、感到羞耻。这是一种后天习得的行为。这是一种后天习得的习惯。当我们进行非常艰难的自传式工作，回溯我们的记忆和过去时，通常这些会变得非常清晰，非常迅速。你可以看到，你现在对自己的想法和感觉，
and the things your younger self encountered and internalized. I'm going to provide an example, my own example here. I think of all the shame that I have felt about my body for years, and it was so hard to even think of where that may have come from because my opinions of my bodies were just so hurtful to even touch. But when I reflected, I saw this very clear line in my memory, a before and after around a series of events. The first was a picture day when I was seven,
与你年轻时的自己所遭遇并内化的事情之间，存在着一条清晰的线索。我在这里提供一个例子，我自己的例子。我想起多年来我对自己的身材感到的所有羞耻，甚至很难去想这些羞耻感可能从何而来，因为我对身材的看法甚至是那么痛苦，触碰一下都觉得难受。但当我反思时，我在记忆中看到了这条非常清晰的线，围绕着一系列事件的分界线。第一件事是我七岁时的拍照日，
and I don't know if you remember this, but we did our big class photo. And I remember getting the photo and the boy, this boy said that it looked like a whale. I was wearing this little dress and I kind of looked at all the other girls and I was just like, oh my God, I'm bigger than them. Bear in mind, I was seven. Like, I wasn't, like, look at that. Now I feel the need to justify. I'm going to stop myself there. But I remember, like, taking the photo home and telling my mom that I was like, oh, there was a fan behind me.
我不知道你还记不记得，我们拍了集体大班照。我记得拿到照片后，有个男孩说这看起来像一头鲸鱼。我当时穿着一件小裙子，我看了看其他所有的女孩，心里想：“天哪，我比她们体型大。”请记住，我当时只有七岁。我当时并不是……看吧，我现在又觉得有必要为自己辩解了。我得在这里停下来。但我记得把照片拿回家，告诉妈妈说：“哦，我身后有个电扇。”
It was blowing my dress up. That's why I have such a belly. It's really sad to think of now. But that's how I felt. And that was my first experience of shame. And then maybe a week later, I was at after-school care. And we were watching a movie. And I remember what it's called.
它把我的裙子吹起来了。这就是为什么我看起来有这么大个肚子。现在想起来真的很让人难过。但那就是我的感受。那是我的第一次羞耻体验。然后大概一周后，我在课后托管班。我们在看一部电影。我记得那叫什么来着。
It was called The Little Princess. And a much older boy said to me, you know, you would look like her, meaning the main character, if you weren't so fat. And oh my God, I can still remember how I just had this like hot flush all across my face and my skin was like pringly. like, oh, just felt more, I wanted to hide. And that was the moment that I think I was like, oh, this is a new feeling. This is the feeling. This is shame. It's really kind of sad to relive those memories.
它叫《小公主》。一个比我大得多的男孩对我说：“你知道吗，如果你不那么胖的话，你看起来就会像她（指主角）一样。”天哪，我至今还记得当时我的脸是如何一阵阵发烫，皮肤感觉刺痛。就像，哦，只想变得更隐蔽，我想找个地缝钻进去。那一刻，我想我当时的感觉是：“哦，这是一种新的感觉。这就是这种感觉。这就是羞耻。”重新经历那些回忆真的让人有点难过。
But the self-knowledge that came with that was so powerful, you know, to be an adult, knowing so much better now and kind of rethinking how I would have responded. I know I would have stood up for my seven, I think maybe seven or eight, old self. And so now, now that it's my own thoughts that are saying those cruel things, you look fat in that outfit, everyone is going to think so, you know, you should wear something more flattering, you should cover up. You know, that's my own voice now telling me those things. But I picture that voice as this 10-year-old boy. And I think, oh my gosh, what do you know? You're a child. Shut up. I'm an adult. You're 10. I'm the adult. I'm going to wear what I want.
但随之而来的自我认知是如此强大，你知道的，作为一个成年人，现在懂得了更多，并且重新思考我会如何回应。我知道我会站出来保护那个七岁（我想大概七岁或八岁）的自己。所以现在，既然是我的脑海在说那些残酷的话——“你穿那套衣服看起来很胖”、“每个人都会这么想”、“你知道的，你应该穿得更显瘦一点”、“你应该遮盖一下”——你知道的，现在是我自己的声音在对我说这些话。但我把那个声音想象成一个十岁的小男孩。我想：“天哪，你懂什么？你只是个小孩。闭嘴。我是个成年人。你才十岁。我是成年人。我想穿什么就穿什么。”
So that's how I picture it. I picture it is the first voice that I heard it as. You know, when that shame was implanted in my brain, it was spoken as a 10-year-old and I think about him and, you know, he's a fucking kid. I don't need to listen to that. That's one approach. Or I also think about myself as a child, suddenly being very awoken to a world of judgment and unkindness and it must have been such a shock.
这就是我的想象方式。我把它想象成我听到的第一个声音。你知道吗，当那种羞耻感被植入我的大脑时，它是以一个十岁孩子的口吻说出来的，我想到了他，你知道的，他他妈就是个孩子。我根本不需要听他的。这是一种方法。或者我也把自己想象成一个孩子，突然被唤醒到一个充满评判和不友善的世界里，那一定是一个巨大的打击。
And I think how would my present adult self comfort her? if adult me had been in that building watching that situation ready to intervene what would I have done I would have pulled her aside and I would have said you have value no matter what anyone else thinks I think you are the most beautiful girl in the world and you deserve to love your body because it does so much for you look about look at how it takes care of you you don't need to hide for anyone especially not this boy and confidence is going to be your superpower and I would say those things when you are reflecting on those origins of your shame, consciously bring empathy, kindness, compassion back into those
我想，我现在的成年自己会怎么去安慰她？如果成年的我在那栋大楼里观看那个情况并准备介入，我会怎么做？我会把她拉到一边对她说：“无论别人怎么想，你都有价值。我认为你是世界上最美丽的女孩，你值得去爱自己的身体，因为它为你做了那么多事情。看看它是怎么照顾你的。你不需要为任何人隐藏自己，尤其是不要为了这个男孩。自信将成为你的超能力。”当我反思羞耻感的起源时，我会把同理心、善良和慈悲重新带回那些
memories. Because shame is so socially orientated. Often we think that we need others to approve of us in order to heal from it, but there is a lot of self-forgiveness that you can provide yourself. For me, it was about apologising to my younger self, forever believing that this person knew who I was, or forever believing that I needed to hide, forever believing that something was wrong about me. I've learnt that's not the case. And now I'm going to go forward and you're going to go forward, nurturing the part of you that still wants to withdraw
记忆中。因为羞耻感具有强烈的社会导向性。通常我们认为我们需要别人的认可才能从中疗愈，但你可以给予自己很多的自我宽恕。对当时的自己而言，就是去向年幼的自己道歉，因为自己曾永远相信这个人知道我是谁，或者永远相信我需要隐藏自己，永远相信我身上有什么地方是不对的。我已经了解到事实并非如此。现在我要前行，你们也要前行，去滋养你内心那个仍然想要退缩的部分，
and instead showing up as this big protector, this big strong person, this adult who is going to defend you. We also want to practice the kind of unconditional love that we've always craved by showing it to ourselves. don't hide from the shame. In fact, speak it out loud. I'm ashamed of my past. I'm ashamed of who I am. I'm ashamed of my body. And yet, and yet, I choose to love myself anyways because I'm as deserving of love as anyone else. I love others unconditionally so I can love myself the same way. In fact, think about all the people who know and love you, not because they're forced to, but because they want to. They want to be by
并转而以一个伟大的保护者、一个坚强的人、一个将要捍卫你的成年人的姿态出现。我们还希望通过向自己展现我们一直渴望的无条件之爱来进行练习。不要躲避羞耻感。事实上，大声说出来：“我为自己的过去感到羞耻。我为我是谁感到羞耻。我为我的身材感到羞耻。然而，然而，我依然选择爱自己，因为我和其他人一样值得被爱。我无条件地爱别人，所以我也能以同样的方式爱自己。”事实上，想想所有那些了解并爱你的人，不是因为他们被迫这么做，而是因为他们发自内心地想这样做。他们想要陪伴在
your side. They have the freedom to be friends with anyone, and they are choosing with that freedom to love you. It's just a further proof of how brilliant you are. And wouldn't they love you even more? the more they saw of you? Reflect on your own relationships here. Doesn't your love only grow with more vulnerability? When someone shows you more of who they are, don't you just love them more? That goes both ways.
你身边。他们有自由去和任何人交友，而他们正用这种自由选择去爱。这正是你有多么优秀的又一证明。而且，难道他们不是越深入了解你，就会越爱你吗？反思一下你自己的人际关系。难道你的爱不是随着更多的脆弱感而增长的吗？当有人向你展示更多真实的自我时，难道你不会更爱他们吗？这是双向的。
Finally, I want you to question what staying small out of shame, what's it going to get you? And is that actually your dream destination in life? What is the cost of staying small versus the benefit of staying safe shame is just fear and fear is something you don't have to listen to it's a fear of failure it's a fear of embarrassment of loneliness as we discussed before and when you have your last moments on this earth do you want to think oh i'm so glad i let myself be scared
最后，我想让你去质疑：因为羞耻而选择缩小自己、唯唯诺诺，这到底能为你带来什么？这真的是你人生中梦想的目的地吗？保持渺小的代价与保持安全的收益相比究竟如何？羞耻感不过是恐惧，而恐惧是你完全不必去听的东西。它是对失败的恐惧，是对尴尬的恐惧，正如我们之前讨论过的，是对孤独的恐惧。当你在这个地球上的最后时刻到来时，你难道想说：“哦，我真高兴我让自己感到害怕，
that was a great decision or do you want to think i'm so glad i let myself be free i'm so glad i listened to the people that mattered and I ignored the rest. I'm so glad I let myself be authentic, vulnerable. I put myself out there. I took risks on myself. I just knew who the fuck I was. And I want a serious answer from you, because I do believe that you can overcome chronic shame if you see what waits on the other side. That is a very motivating thing. And for me, you know, it's just been, as we said, total acceptance. because why would I live my life based on what a mean voice says to me in my head? When that's not even my voice, someone else's voice that's just snuck in there. It's not welcome.
那真是个明智的决定”？还是你想说：“我真高兴我让自己获得了自由。我真高兴我听取了那些重要之人的意见，而忽略了其余的杂音。我真高兴我让自己变得真实、脆弱。我勇敢地展现了自我。我为自己承担了风险。我清楚地知道自己他妈的是谁。”我需要你给我一个认真的回答，因为我相信，如果你能看到另一端等待着你的是什么，你就能克服慢性羞耻感。那是一件非常有动力的事情。对我而言，正如我们所说，这仅仅是彻底的接受。因为我为什么要根据我脑海中一个刻薄声音对我说的话来过我的人生呢？当那甚至都不是我的声音，而是某个不知哪来的声音悄悄溜了进来。它根本不受欢迎。
For me, that has really helped me build a courage to try anything and everything, even if it goes wrong. It's resulted in the ability to commit to my dreams because I deserve them. it's evolved into the capacity to accept love. And I really want that for you. It does make me quite sad to think of how many of us don't realize that the root of everything we don't like about ourselves is not the fact that those things aren't worthy. It's that we just feel shameful about them. And shame is not a fact, it's a feeling.
对我来说，这真的帮助我建立了尝试任何事情的勇气，无论结果如何。它让我有能力去践行自己的梦想，因为我配得上它们。它最终演变成了一种接受爱的能力。我真的很希望你也能拥有这种能力。一想到我们当中有那么多的人没有意识到，我们不喜欢自己的所有根源，其实并不是因为这些东西不值得，而是因为我们对它们感到羞耻，这确实让我感到相当难过。而羞耻感不是事实，它只是一种感觉。
You know, the parts about yourself that you don't like, there is nothing inherently bad about them. It is that someone at some point has conditioned you, taught you, to feel that way. And I don't want you to feel that way anymore. So I hope that this episode has helped you understand the root of it, has helped you go back and discover the origin, discover the villain, the villain origin story. And I hope that you start treating that younger version of yourself with the kindness that you always deserved. And that includes treating your current self with the kindness that they deserve because you and that childhood self are not different. You're the same person. You're on the same timeline here. If you enjoyed this episode, make sure you're following along. Maybe share it with a friend,
你知道的，关于你自己那些你所不喜欢的部分，它们本身并没有什么不好的。而是某个时候的某个人让你习惯了、教导了你去那样感受。我不想让你再有这种感觉了。所以我希望这一集能帮助你理解它的根源，帮你回溯过去并找到源头，找到反派，找到那个反派的起源故事。我希望你开始用你一直应得的善良去对待那个年轻时的自己。这也包括用应有的善良去对待你现在的自己，因为你和那个童年时的自己并没有区别。你们是同一个人。你们在同一条时间线上。如果你喜欢这一集，请确保点击关注。也许可以把它分享给朋友，
share it with a parent, if they might need to learn this lesson. That's a bit audacious. Just hopefully it reaches the people that it needs to reach. That's all I'm saying. Make sure that you are following us on Instagram at That Psychology podcast. If you have further questions, queries, stories to be shared, please let us know. We would love to hear from you. We're also taking episode suggestions, just slide into our DMs and tell us what you want to hear about. Until next time, remember, stay safe, stay kind, and most importantly with this episode, be gentle with yourself. You don't deserve to live in shame. You don't deserve to be shame-bound, not one bit. And we will talk very, very soon.
或者分享给父母，如果他们可能需要学习这一课的话。这可能有点大胆。但愿它能传达给那些需要听到它的人。我只想说这些。请确保在Instagram上关注我们，账号是That Psychology podcast。如果你有更多的问题、疑问或想分享的故事，请让我们知道。我们很乐意听到你的声音。我们同时也接受节目选题建议，直接私信我们，告诉你想听什么内容。直到下次，记住，保持安全，保持善良，最重要的是，在这一集里，对你自己温柔一点。你不配活在羞耻之中。你一点都不应该被羞耻感所束缚。我们很快就会再聊。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit are armored. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy,
嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难学到的教训》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·加姆斯（Kear Games）。这个节目探讨黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他地方绝对不安全、无法进行的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人把西装当成盔甲？这向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须使用它。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。在2023年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕，
appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
似乎是一场骗局。“欧文斯女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？”“我篡改过一次测试。”这需要一支由网络侦探组成的庞大队伍来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士：格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的脑子彻底炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。
This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
这是《陷入爱河的陷阱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。
I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的全新自我。收听《2%》。即数字2和%。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。
When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
当一群女性发现她们约会过的竟然是同一个多产的世纪骗子时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝。
On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, all. wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方。这是一个iHeart播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。